great
uh can you see and hear me shipra
yeah okay it's my pleasure to have our
next speaker now
uh david goldberg who is uh who is at
cornell orie
and he's going to talk about his
exciting result of optimus stopping
great thanks shipra and connections to
rl i didn't know that you made
connections to ariel already actually
yeah well there's it's
uh yeah so um hey everyone so yeah my
name's dave
um and i'm uh here to talk to you about
some exciting uh
new work about uh high dimensional
control high dimensional optimal
stopping
connections to rl and some really
interesting questions in that space
um as a quick heads up uh unfortunately
i teach today so i won't be able to make
the discussion of this section but i
would love to connect to people
if you have any thoughts etc please just
shoot me an email
and i'm happy to set up a time to chat
and would love your feedback on this
work
and this is joint with a great phd
student elon chen
so with that let's um
[Music]
let's get started so i'm gonna just
sure to interrupt hello uh just
interrupt a little bit
you can speak to 110 see it since we
started a little late
yeah sure sure and i'll try to leave
time for questions also
yeah yeah i don't teach till half fast
so as long as i'm out by 20 after i
think it's okay
no no i think i think let's do let's do
this
keep it on my heart yeah of course yeah
okay very good
so i'm going to start with the punch
line
so optimal stopping um is a key problem
that comes up in financial math
specifically options pricing operations
research
control econ cs it already came up in uh
tsuji challa's talk about uh variants of
the pandora's box problem
it's come up in a lot of pricing
problems revenue management etc
um so although i'm sure you know many
people are are of course familiar with
some of the classical stylized
independent
iid models you get one over e these
kinds of things
it turns out that um in many real world
computational problems where
this this kind of optimal stopping
framework arises um
you actually have things like full path
dependence
and a high dimensional process
generating the information you have to
use to decide whether or not to stop so
it's a very
different universe than kind of these
simple stylized uh
optimal stopping problems that some
people might be uh more familiar with
but in control
and math finance um these kinds of high
dimensional problems are very well
studied and
and fundamental um unsurprisingly
you know and i'll talk about the model
specifically a bit later but
this is considered to be kind of one of
the core
simplest non-trivial high-dimensional uh
control problems so of course
you have the curse of dimensionality
that's kind of common knowledge
i'll be a little uh loose with cursive
dimensionality being roughly equivalent
to you have too many states
and no continuity or anything like this
and so i'll use these two concepts kind
of synonymously
but you can't do kind of naive dynamic
programming um
for that uh reason
and again especially after it became
clear that these problems were
important in mathematical finance and
specifically options pricing
avast literature arose and this this
goes back to the
you know the 90s and even before that um
about you know how can we at least come
up with heuristic methods or other
methods
to try to understand and solve at least
computationally
this interesting family of high
dimensional problems
and so there was a ton of literature on
approximate dynamic programming
simulation based methods duality methods
pde methods
there's a lot of interesting work out
there um and a lot of that work has had
um you know very interesting uh
heuristic and practical success
however i i think that literature does
have um
some some shortcomings and in particular
if you want both provable computational
tractability
and provable error bounds then
effectively all that literature is is is
going out the window
um and that's especially true for fully
path dependent
and high dimensional problems but i note
that
you know really it's captured by even
markovian and high dimensional and of
course even for the path dependent case
you can in principle fold that into an
even nastier uh markov thing by just
making the paths
um states and you know
it was common wisdom that well this is a
genuinely high dimensional
uh control problem of of course you
can't have tractability and error bounds
you know that's that's the common wisdom
so again it for good reason it seems
theoretically intractable and there's
there's a vast literature there across
many disciplines
um there's a very interesting duality
literature
in that space as we'll talk about at
least a little later
um optimal stopping can be searched it
can be
transformed by duality into a search for
a good martingale
we'll talk about that a bit later
there's a lot of literature on that but
it's effectively
a lot of it's very non-constructive and
non-computational
and what computational literature there
is is almost always getting bounds
as opposed to you know simple
computationally efficient
methods for essentially the optimal dual
martingale
um and i know the key issue here
which i'll connect to some some topics
in reinforcement learning in a moment
is that so one might say okay whether
it's independent or not i can of course
do
some kinds of backwards induction for
you know any reasonable control problem
optimal stopping being one of them
um you know if i'm smart about it i can
kind of do that backwards induction
by simulation on the fly so i don't need
to write down
all the states that's true um however
the common wisdom which you know in is
that
if you take that approach and even if
you're smart about it
you still get nested conditional
expectations whose depth of nesting
uh scales with the time horizon and
again i'll later connect this to some
concepts in reinforcement learning
which means backwards induction even if
done cleverly
yields a runtime that scales
exponentially in the time horizon
um and so that that's that's not
uh effective for for solving these
problems
so let me let me kind of
sneak peek the results and give give the
the key takeaways
so we proved that somewhat shockingly um
there's actually a simple and elegant
formula essentially a closed form
formula for this
problem that was believed to be
computationally intractable
as a fairly elegant infinite sum um
and i note that as i'll talk a little
bit about later later terms in the sum
can actually be viewed as a certain kind
of higher order profit inequality for
those who know what that is i'll
be clear when we talk about it um but
okay infinite um maybe
that's kind of a nice mathematical
oddity but maybe it's not
computationally useful
um here even more remarkably we show
that if you truncate that sum after k
terms
you get a a normalized error in in a
fairly simple sense which is bounded by
1 over k not asymptotically but
exactly um and furthermore
each term of this sum is actually easy
and natural to compute by simulation
which is then going to connect
to certain generative rl types of models
and when you put this together and i'll
show that some in a few slides
you get efficient randomized epsilon
approximately optimal algorithms i won't
make the sense of optimality completely
precise but i'm happy to talk to people
if they have questions with a
computational run time which for any
fixed error tolerance epsilon
is polynomial in the time horizon and
effectively independent of the dimension
and totally data driven
um so again for any fixed error uh
tolerance epsilon
is polynomial the time horizon and
effectively independent of the dimension
beating this curse of dimensionality
where i know this is really quite
surprising because it was
it was really thought for a very long
time that this is kind of the simplest
non-trivial high dimensional control
problem which couldn't possibly have
kind of a simple solution like that so
that's that's kind of interesting
we also draw a new connection to network
flows which shows that
essentially the whole theory of duality
for network flows
i mean duality for optimal stopping
which relates to
more subtle notions of duality for uh
stochastic control more broadly and
martingale methods there
can actually be uh understood more or
less entirely
uh through the classical max flowman cut
theory
for network flows and that actually
gives a nice way to unify and
reinterpret
a lot of this duality literature for
high dimensional optimal stopping
and perhaps in some sense for just
stochastic control more broadly
and i want to stress this is a potential
new hammer we're very excited about it
and it could have a lot of other
applications in math finance econ cs
control
or and i already point to one thing that
i'm definitely going to follow up with
with such a on is you know in sushi's
talk there was discussion about
if you fix the order of a pandora's uh
box type of setup with general
correlation structure you you get a high
dimensional optimal stopping problem
that
okay they show when you have the special
structure you can get kind of a
profit inequality and get a constant
factor approximation
with this method you can essentially
solve that complicated optimal stopping
problem at least for a fixed order so
that
that introduces a already from this
workshop an interesting connection but
if
people have more please let me know okay
now i'm going to talk about the rl
connection just i know some of you may
be a little less familiar with the
literature on optimal stopping
so i'm going to connect this uh to rl um
which which may make it a little more
clear for some experts in the audience
and
open uh some interesting bridges between
these areas
um so okay so
as i kind of said vaguely before optimal
stopping can be thought of as a high
dimensional
mdp um where again high dimensional is
really just a proxy for having many
states
where the point is you have this high
dimensional information
you could think about like a bunch of
economic indicators and stock values
evolving
in a a complicated way um
and associated to each complicated
vector you have a single
if i stop now what cost do i incur
and this moves around and you need to
decide when to stop
and incur the cost for the current state
even though those high dimensional
dynamics might be very complicated
when you think about it that way it's
it's it's clear it's just a high
dimensional mdp
um and if i insist that you work from
samples
and again so for this talk when i say
work from samples i mean
okay yes when you're solving the problem
you're on a given trajectory and need to
decide when to stop
but i am assuming that you have a black
box where
even though this is the world the path
you're on and this is the decision you
have to make
to make that decision you can plug in
whatever states you want
um and hit a button and get a get a a
trajectory there
which is just reinforcement learning
within the kind of generative model
framework
um and so today's talk can be
interpreted as
a a very interesting uh special case of
reinforcement learning in a generative
model generative framework although i do
want to point out that
again thinking about this bridge between
reinforcement learning and high
dimensional control
um optimal stopping in the optimal
stopping literatures it's widely
understood that this problem is
computationally intractable
even if you have the model and there's
no learning
samples or anything like that um like if
you could query a joint density function
explicitly if there existed one
i won't dwell on that now it's it's well
known for much
much time now and where one of the you
know cleanest expositions on this goes
goes back at least to sham cocked his uh
thesis
that if you're in the setting of um
reinforcement learning with a generative
model
um then the common wisdom is you can't
really escape
a computational complexity that's either
exponential in the dimension which again
for us means roughly
depends you know polynomially or
linearly on the number of states
or you need to be exponential in the
time horizon and that's roughly for the
same reason that you can always do
backwards induction in some kind of
naive way
um and trade off dependence on the
state's space
for exponential dependence on the time
horizon it's it's conceptually
uh kind of the same thing going on and
there's many works
um great works by by many people in the
audience who are have far more expertise
than that than i
um that there's there's lots of
interesting work on lower bounds here
and the kind of fundamental
computational trade-offs in
reinforcement learning
um depending on you know which of these
things do you want to pay a price in
um so of course an interesting question
is um are there interesting
high-dimensional models where you can
overcome both these
where you cannot pay one of these two
terrible prices
um and furthermore we're gonna ask
can you do this for both sample and
computational complexity so not just
maybe i know i don't need a ton of
samples but i don't know how to do the
computation we want it all
and we don't want any niceness
assumptions where by niceness i mean
something like
you know low rank in the sense of rank
of an mdp or
something mixes nicely or the costs are
continuous in the state or there's some
kind of linearity
or things can be embedded in in a metric
space or or something like this so
we want essentially no such kind of nice
structural assumptions can we really
tackle the high dimensionality heads on
where again the common wisdom is that
the answer should be
uh no but we show that yes
um for high dimensional optimal stopping
the answer is actually yes
um and what i'm gonna do now is connect
our results at a very high level to kind
of an approximate dynamic programming
way of thinking
um and in particular the formula that
i'll show you
you can think of is yielding a
universally good set of basis functions
where roughly the terms of the sum
um can be thought of as as a certain
kind of
uh very very carefully chosen basis
function
and you will use your polynomial number
of samples to simulate
and evaluate these um these basis
functions
one thing i want to point out that again
for for for people that may be experts
in the
lower bounds on these problems and say
that that is doesn't make any sense
i do note that when i talk about the
runtime bounds etc
i am not insisting that at the end of
the day we output a massive table that
says for every state would you have
stopped there or not
um when i talk about these runtimes it's
only for the question of
if you're actually solving the problem
in real time and you you haven't stopped
yet and this is the state you're at
do you stop or not and it's it's so
these these guarantees are for on the
fly
uh decision making where i know and i'll
talk a little bit more at the end
there's interesting questions about how
this all connects to the landscape of rl
and lower bounds there
and i'll tease uh you know a theme that
i want to leave people with and again if
people have thoughts i'd love to to talk
a very big question here is what other
high dimensional rl problems can we
solve without making kind of niceness
assumptions um
please yes hi hi uh
yeah so i'm just this one the nice
assumptions and versus
uh what you're doing here uh could be
considered a nice
assumption uh of its special kind uh
you actually say that this is like uh
having a good set of basis functions
uh for this class of problems so to me
uh it seems difficult to a priory make a
distinction
between restricting the class of
problems the way you do it
just say that like it's optimal stopping
i put no other
sections but because it's optimal
stopping
it comes its own structure uh versus
if i say that okay i want to use linear
basis functions so a linear
you know function approximation uh they
seem to be
quite related actually sure so that's a
great point
um and so maybe instead of niceness uh
no niceness assumptions i i would say
maybe
no standard niceness assumptions would
be uh or no
you know common wisdom currently well
studied niceness assumptions where
indeed i think there's almost certainly
little hope
of having such efficient methods for
just general reinforcement learning or
high dimensional control
and there's there's negative results out
there going back to you know
ticklish and others even before that and
so yes i guess
um here maybe uh um
this would be saying is this teasing at
maybe a new notion of niceness which is
look
here is a well-studied family of
high-dimensional problems for which
nobody thought
that without making additional
smoothness assumptions you'd be able to
solve it
but it is definitely not all of rl etc
and so yeah that's that's a great point
and that that would be my quick
uh thought on that good
um okay so moving
on to the um model
and um problem so i'm gonna give
most of the talk not in an rl kind of
frame but in kind of a just classical
optimal stopping frame but if people
have questions about how it connects i'm
happy to elucidate
so we're gonna be in the discrete time
setting with capital t periods i do note
that if if someone
would rather think in kind of a
discounted thing then you could roughly
change
t for one over one minus discount factor
if if that's close to one
um but it's most easily thought of
perhaps in the discrete time
setting for the kinds of methods uh
we'll be talking about so finite large
horizon you should be thinking about
um we have a so-called information
process which we've written as a
a filtration um but you don't have to
think about
filtration here you can just think about
um you have a high dimensional
uh sequence of vectors that you're
seeing in an online way
y1 y2 y3 etc through yt
where again um each of the y's is a
capital d dimensional and you think
about capital d
as being pretty large say something like
polynomial in the time horizon
um so it's not kind of a fix
d kind of setting um and so this
information
is evolving over time possibly in a
non-markovian way
if you wanted to fold it into a
markovian thinking that wouldn't really
change
much about the punch line but that's
effectively the history of the y's the
trajectory of the y's
is effectively your your state in some
um sense um we're going to talk about uh
cost functions um these little g sub ts
where this is the cost of stopping at
time t and that's you evaluate this
a little g cost function on all the y's
you've seen so far
and that's you know that's that's this
kind of classical general optimal
stopping setting i use the bracket
notation for the
trajectory of the y's so far again each
y
is a capital d dimensional vector um
it could even be more abstract but i
just use this to to
make things concrete i also note that
the same ideas would in principle work
in continuous time
although to get an algorithmic statement
you'd have to think about what what that
would mean precisely with no extra
assumptions
um and we don't really make any
assumptions
uh here but you just think about it as
kind of non-negative and integrable
um even though you could kind of do away
with that with one round of the method
um that i'll explain so this is kind of
the
basic set up i do know we work in the
minimization setting here
because um we'll later see that actually
because the max flowman cut connection
minimization is a bit more natural
um we let script t be the set of adapted
stopping times
um where again it uh adapted stopping
time is just
you know based on the whys you've seen
so far you have to decide whether to
stop or not
and the problem of interest is just pick
the stopping time to minimize the
expected value of when you stop
so uh the technical results we do are
actually very intuitive and simple and
i'm going to present the main idea uh
quickly um so
let's denote the optimal value by this
best you can do over all stopping times
there's a trivial lower bound of course
this is roughly the so-called profit
inequality
you can't do better than how good you
could do if you got to see everyone in
advance
oh sorry let me point out i let zt
denote
this gt evaluated on the y so far
so it's a random variable which
represents if you haven't stopped yet
and you stop at time t
what's the cost you incur so again you
have this trivial kind of profit
inequality um where you'd say well the
best you can do is at least the expected
value of the best in hindsight
that's that's not uh very complicated
um but now incredibly that's actually
half of the idea
all we're going to do is turn that into
an equality
using one single application of the
optional stopping theorem
let me briefly remind people the
optional stopping theorem says for any
martingale
the expected value of that martingale
evaluated at a stopping time
is just the expected value of that
martingale at time one
um i note that okay there's some mild
regularity conditions on the martingale
but they won't be relevant
uh for us here so let me talk about how
we're gonna use that
so what i'm going to do is define a new
process
z2 z2
is going to be i'm going to call our
original process z1
and i'm going to define a new process z2
which is our original process
minus the dew martingale associated with
the all-time men of our original process
so it's the original process minus a
martingale and that's a very carefully
chosen martingale namely again
the martingale evaluated at time t is my
best guess of the all-time men of my
original process given the
information i have up to time t now
let's think about why i can um why this
equality i have for opt up there holds
suppose i do optimal stopping on my z2
process right then since for
any stopping time whatsoever when i
evaluate that second term the martingale
subtracted off on the stopping time its
value does not depend on that specific
stopping time
the fact that i've subtracted that off
does not meaningfully change the
optimization
it just translates it by the expected
value of that martingale
which allows us just by that very simple
logic there's nothing up the sleeve
there
we we can say that the uh optimal value
is the expected value of the min of the
original process
plus the best i can do on this new
process my z2 processor
a key point is that because my best
guess of the min
given what i know now is always smaller
than the value i'm looking at now
the z2 process is actually non-negative
and it's it's
stochastically below this the original
process
and of course what am i going to do now
i'm just going to say well the z3s
i'm going to define z3s as i'm just
going to bootstrap that process on the
z2s
and if i repeat that logic i get my
original optimal value is e of the min
of the original process plus e of the
min of this z2 process
you can think about the z2 processor is
almost like a regret
process in some sense plus kind of a
remaining stopping problem on
um the z3s
and i simply keep recursing this and i
get that the
original optimal value is if i keep
recursing this the expected value of the
min and z1
plus the expected value of the minus z2s
etc plus
um some kind of limiting remainder term
but that limiting remainder term goes to
zero and we'll actually discuss the rate
explicitly
that's the whole logic that's that's
really much of the proof
it's just the rate of convergence of
that error term which proof i won't
share with you
is one over k but it's actually just
just a page long proof if that
um so let me give the first few terms
the first term is just
the profit the original profit
inequality the expected value of the
all-time men
the second term is is an interesting
kind of next step of that profit
thinking where it's the expected value
of the men of a certain kind of regret
process
now one might think um that this regret
kind of process here might
degenerate and just trivialize to zero
but it does not um why is that that's
because right at the start of the
horizon
it's this value you're looking at minus
your best guess of the men
with all this stuff you haven't yet seen
because you haven't seen it
um that's going to be some non-trivial
thing but at the end
it's the thing you're looking at minus
the best
of all the things you have seen which is
probably all the way back here
and so it's non-trivial the whole way
through and the next term is just kind
of a
uh uh once more stepper curse of that
same logic
and again the key theorem is that if you
truncate that sum after k
terms and your original process was
bounded so the only
uh assumption we have whatsoever is that
your rewards are bounded
um the the error is just one over k
which yields um if you truncate after k
terms and that essentially yields all
our algorithms
although we do prove other bounds under
slightly stronger assumptions if you
have no upper bound on your rewards
process etc and we note for for our
method
this is tied in the worst case um but it
seems to converge much faster for many
examples and we are working on
other types of expansions that maybe
would be even faster
so let me just briefly talk about the
algorithmic implications
so again you know if you just look at
this slide it's it's kind of intuitively
clear that
to compute the k term here you just need
kind of
depth k nested access to your simulator
which is really just
depth k nested simulations that you can
do just with
the regular simulator um
and there's no curse of dimensionality
the dimensionality only arises in your
need to simulate
trajectories of the original process
which
you know whether that can be overcome or
not is not is not clear
again it's completely data driven it's
all based on simulation in the same
sense of like a degenerative kind of rl
model
um and although the complexity increases
as you need more terms because the error
is at most one over k
you only need a few terms this yields
fairly simple analysis which yields
explicit runtime bounds depending
on exactly what kind of error you want
of the form for any fixed epsilon
polynomial in t
um this is true not only for computing
the value but for actually
implementing a policy um so you get uh
efficient stopping strategies
also so let me talk briefly about this
max flow min cut connection
so optimal stopping says for every
trajectory of your high dimensional
information
process you need to pick a time t to
stop
what does min cut say min cut says for
every path
from source to syncing your network you
have to pick an edge to cut
and it turns out that the whole theory
of optimal stopping duality
can actually be re-envisioned by mapping
optimal stopping high dimensional
optimal stopping to a natural uh
uh kind of network um
in which you've rigged it so each path
corresponds to a trajectory of your
information process
and the capacity of the cut is rigged to
kind of correspond
to the expected performance of a
stopping time um
that you you actually can express um
essentially the much of the theory of
duality for optimal stopping and
some related matters and just stochastic
control using
uh max flow min cut and this unifies a
lot of duality results that are out
there for optimal stopping
and give some simpler proofs and
intuition about a lot of past results
and we note that
our algorithm can actually be
interpreted as a very fast randomized
iterative method for solving
max flow on a massive tree actually in
the same spirit as what are now being
called so-called quantum-inspired
methods
um and that's all i'll say about
that i think i'll just move on so
let me just uh briefly talk about some
interesting ongoing work
um so we're working on kind of a fast
implementation
um that could actually be used in
financial applications um
that kind of you know has combines our
work with some interesting hacks and new
insights
to make it even faster um there's a lot
of interesting generalizations here
you know just to give one example
already uh the pandora's box problem
from sushi's talk
those extensions uh some of them are
more more kind of
uh clear there's you know multiple
stopping for for example pricing swing
options
there's dynamic pricing um we have some
interesting uh
work that we're we're working on
completing on online combinatorial
optimization with unstructured
high-dimensional
covariates um you know revenue
management
uh some interesting questions in in the
computation of gittins indices
sequential statistics and change point
detection
again as i said our expansion can be
roughly interpreted as kind of a higher
order
refinement to the classical profit
inequality um
so there's you know no doubt interesting
connections there
um we do hope that that one day these
methods might actually be useful to
someone there's obviously been some very
high stakes optimal stopping problems
with
when do we close various um entities
during this terrible situation we're in
um
and again i think a really interesting
question so i'll just jump
to the the very end um
is as was kind of asking a question at
the very beginning
i would say are there other notions of
niceness
of kind of high dimensional rl that are
maybe quite different than those
typically
uh appearing in the literature today
um for which nonetheless high
dimensional control and and rl might be
tractable and how does this relate
to lower bounds in the literature for rl
um especially in a generative model and
the kinds of trade-offs
that manifest there all in there again
unfortunately i can't stick around for
the discussion but if anyone has any
thoughts i'd love to maybe quickly hear
some of them now
and please send me an email i'd love to
chat thank you very much
thanks david uh uh digging can you start
sharing a screen soon soon while others
can ask questions yeah let me stop
shooting
yeah yeah
can i ask a quick question maybe
please um it's very interesting talk
it's
it's very very nice and it's indeed
going in a different direction than
all the other things that people were
trying uh
it's really awesome um so
it seems that there are multiple things
going on with optimal stopping
uh and you must have been wondering
which which of these are uh crucial for
this type of argument yes yes
do you have some thoughts i do have a
thought there so
the online combinatorial problem where
we've been able to extend this
so far is um bipartite max weight
independent set with high dimensional
feature information and why is that that
is because
you can express the control problem as a
massive max flow problem
where you can then
[Music]
use certain properties of packing lps
residual networks etc
to think about solving it in some kind
of ultraly
parallel simulation based way
where and this also draws a connection
some between the vast literature on
parallel algorithms on massive graphs
and networks
and the fact that when you have a high
dimensional control problem
it has a simulation structure built into
it
like generative rl generative control
with a generative model has access to a
simulator
in a certain sense baked in if you
thought about a massive graph where the
costs
actually had possibly nasty
probabilities on them
in some kind of sense and so
strong connection to flows and packing
lps in some way
to what extent it can go beyond that
also a connection to quantum inspired
algorithms
as i said this would say i know i don't
know if anyone here is is
familiar at all with this growing work
on so-called quantum-inspired algorithms
for various problems in tcs which
roughly say
if you give me a simulator i can give
you an algorithm
um and in some sense our work can be
thought of as as a
a certain take on that in a certain way
related to flows and there'd be a
question of
when can one uh think about methods like
that for high dimensional rl and control
more broadly
that would be my answer but great
question thank you okay
i i do have a technical question as well
uh
regarding the abstract i guess i missed
the definition of epsilon is it
absolute error relative yeah so the the
simplest version of the results is an
additive epsilon error
okay translating it is in the
minimization framework additive epsilon
error when things are bounded between
say zero
when the costs are bounded between zero
and one you get a completely clean
result
if you want to move to maximization with
relative error etc
at least our current results do need to
throw in some kind of moment
consideration or something like this
to what extent you know various notions
of of approximation
change things it's not clear i do know
that there so there is a literature on
the computational complexity of
stochastic optimization
etc again going back at least to johnson
cyclists
and christos uh work there from a while
ago but i do still think
because a lot of this these models fall
outside the standard turing machine
framework
there's still some very interesting
questions about bridging the
computational
complexity question between the kind of
lower bounds appearing in the rl
literature and kind of absolute hardness
kinds of things i know some people are
more expertise on that and are thinking
about it but i
i do think that there's still some some
great questions there
that that that would be my answer thank
you okay
thanks right thank you david uh let's
move on to the
third talk of the sessions uh sorry for
delaying